[Music]
hey everybody awesome news you may have
heard about the Titans TV show casting
it's Nightwing all the other big
characters they also just cast Hawk and
Dove Alan Ritchson who played Aquaman on
Smallville as well as Minka Kelly who's
playing dove in the thing is they
haven't even debuted the series yet they
haven't even shot the first episode but
they're eyeballing Hawk and Dove for a
spin-off series from Titans on that DC
streaming service so I'll explain what's
going on as well as what's up with hawk
and doves powers and what they might
look like on the TV show so if you're
new to the channel or you've been gone
during the summer make sure you click
that Bell to enable alerts so you don't
miss any of the videos there's gonna be
a lot of stuff dropping really soon
there is new giveaway stuff that I'll
explain at the end of the video too but
you may have seen my last Titans video
that I did when they announced who their
Nightwing was so obviously that's gonna
be a really big deal we get to see him
become Nightwing over the course of the
TV show it's post Robin but pre
Nightwing so he's becoming Nightwing as
they bring the Titans together but
whereas the Titans are just coming
together for the first time Hawk and
Dove sound like they've been sort of
their own solo act for a while and they
sort of cross paths with the Titans and
they'll just pop in and out of the
stories I don't know if there'll be main
characters during the first season but
if they're eyeballing them for a
spin-off series that means that they'll
probably be featured quite a bit
remember the way they did Barry Allen on
arrow they introduced him in a two-part
episode then he went off to his own
pilot series the reason why that was a
little bit different is is because the
flash is one of the biggest DC Comics
characters the adora T 100% decided to
do a flash TV show it was just a
question of how they were gonna
introduce the character into the
arrowverse and whether or not it was
gonna be a pilot or if it was gonna be a
backdoor pilot but with this Huck and
Duff yeah you have a couple big actors
it's totally possible it could be an
awesome series but the characters aren't
that big and even though Minka Kelly is
a stone-cold Fox she's freaking hot in
Alan Ritchson could totally wreck it
people wanted him to be Shazam for a
while I think a lot of the success of
these new comic book TV shows is
directly tied to which characters
they're doing like if you don't do a
character that people like it's gonna be
10 times
harder to get people to watch the series
even if they're really awesome episodes
you already have so many arrow verse
shows with the big a-list characters so
I'll just say right up front that even
though I'm expecting them to be awesome
on Titan's I just don't think that
they're big enough for their own TV show
I don't think it's gonna wind up
happening but if you're not familiar
with the characters everybody knows that
Hawk and Dove come together but I don't
think that everybody totally understands
how their powers work where they come
from Hawk
[Music]
so the whole thing is that they activate
their bird related powers by saying
their names Hawk and Dove so it's sort
of like Shazam you say Shazam Billy
Batson becomes Shazam or Captain Marvel
if you still want to call him that
technically DC isn't allowed to call him
Captain Marvel anymore but Hawk and Dove
get their powers from the Lords of chaos
and order so if that sounds kind of
weird because they have Marvel
characters that are also called that
then yeah they might change that for the
TV show just a little bit so whenever
they beat the crap out of whatever
trouble is happening whenever they save
the day their powers just sort of go
away automatically it's sort of an
automatic on/off switch the big
difference with hawks powers like as you
can see he looks pretty crazy he's sort
of like a proto Red Lantern type
character limitless rage whereas dove
has energy projection powers Hawk really
just Hulk's out so just imagine Alan
Ritchson going crazy on everybody in a
dark alley like he were a Red Lantern
but part of the reason why it's so
critical that they stayed together is
because dove has this ability where she
balances his emotions out so he doesn't
wind up killing everybody he turned into
a full-blown supervillain at least twice
in the comics so we might actually see
that happen at some point in the show or
just tease the idea that he is teetering
on the edge of becoming a super villain
and you're not really sure if he's a
hero or if he's gonna be a villain but
then Dov walks in and he chills out a
little bit the greatest supernatural
roid-rage you could possibly imagine
speaking of which some of you might
remember Alan Ritchson from Blue
Mountain State where he played a
football player Stephen Amell Oliver
Queen was a guest star on that TV show a
long time before he ever became the
Green Arrow
he's our starting quarterback and it's
the biggest game of the season
we're playing Overland you can't take
him away from me why he was arrested
with a prostitute come on he was set up
the kid does missionary work for Christ
God dancing that was mostly a comedy
series but it also starred Pete from
Smallville so this is big meta
Smallville DC TV thing
that's going on we're actors just pop up
on each other shows but if you've seen
brave in the bold or Justice League
Unlimited they've been in a couple
episodes but it was the earlier version
of the Dove character there been a
couple different versions of the
character the first version of Dove was
a man it was Hank and Don Hall this
version of Dove is the second version
she'll be dawn Granger in they have a
sort of implied relationship but it's
kind of abusive so I wouldn't be
surprised if dove on the TV show on
Titan's winds up getting into a
relationship with Nightwing or someone
else there's all this funny stuff that
goes on behind the scenes within the
Titans team if you've seen any of the TV
shows or ever read the comics there's a
lot of soap opera that's built into it
which is really kind of funny because
most of the time Cory either walks
around naked or in a bikini so it just
throws everybody off their game it'll be
interesting to see how funny the show
gets with stuff like that
I think they'll tone it down just a
little bit like I don't think they're
gonna make this Starfire actress walk
around in a bikini every single episode
but here's a little bit of what their
powers look like on screen ha you're
with me dub I'm on it
both of you scram
[Music]
so as you can see super speed super
strength stuff like that that's easy for
them to do on the television shows I
don't know about energy projection we'll
see about that when they're in their
avatar state they're actually beings of
pure light even though they appear human
so when they get wounded when their
costumes get ripped off you see their
true form and it's just like this bright
shining light so we might see a version
of that on the TV show too so just
remember that the Dove will be the
female version of the character
obviously Minka Kelly does not look like
a man that would be very awkward but in
terms of special-effects stunts fight
scenes the Titans show will be able to
do anything that you've seen before on
the DC TV shows congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner / Lord Kinsey
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details while you wait for
everything click here to learn about
more of the titans cast and you can
click here for a brand new thor footage
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight